Sponsored by Newport Healthcare, providing results-driven mental health care for teens and young adults ages 12 to 28, who are struggling with trauma, depression, anxiety, and other mood personality and co-occurring disorders. At Newport Healthcare, tailored treatment plans foster sustainable healing to help young people move from struggling to thriving. Learn more at newporthealthcare.com. For those of us who speak only one language, or maybe even speak two or three, the idea of learning 20 or 30 sounds impossible. But there are people who have managed this remarkable feat. They're called hyper polyglots. There's no official definition of hyper polyglotism.
本节目由Newport Healthcare赞助，为12至28岁受创伤、抑郁、焦虑及其他情绪、人格和共病障碍困扰的青少年和年轻人提供以结果为导向的心理健康护理。在Newport Healthcare，量身定制的治疗方案旨在促进可持续的康复，帮助年轻人从挣扎走向蓬勃发展。详情请访问newporthealthcare.com。对于我们这些只会说一种语言，或者可能只会说两三种语言的人来说，学习20或30种语言的想法似乎是不可能的。但有些人已经完成了这一壮举。他们被称为“超多语者”。目前对“超多语”并没有官方定义。
The International Association of Hyper Polyglots welcomes members who speak six or more languages, but some hyper polyglots speak dozens with varying degrees of fluency. So what sets hyper polyglots apart? Are they simply smarter than the rest of us, or harder working, or more motivated to learn? If you put them in a functional magnetic resonance imaging scanner, do their brains look different from those of monolingles or bilinguals? And what might scientists discover about how the brain processes language by studying people with remarkable language abilities? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Ev
国际超多语者协会欢迎那些会说六种或更多语言的成员，但一些超多语者能以不同程度的流利度说几十种语言。那么，是什么让超多语者与众不同呢？他们只是比我们其他人更聪明、更努力，还是学习动力更强？如果你把他们放进功能性磁共振成像扫描仪中，他们的大脑看起来会与单语者或双语者有什么不同吗？通过研究这些拥有非凡语言能力的人，科学家们能发现大脑处理语言的哪些奥秘？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是埃夫博士。
Federenko. Dr. Federenko is an associate professor in the Department of Brain and Cognitive Sciences at the Massachusetts Institute of Technology, where she explores how people understand and produce language. She uses brain imaging and other research methods to study healthy individuals and people with language-related brain disorders, as well as hyper polyglots. Among the questions she's interested in are what's the relationship between language and other cognitive abilities? Can we think without language? What is the organization of the language system in our brain? And how does it emerge in childhood and change over the course of a lifetime?
费德连科博士。费德连科博士是麻省理工学院大脑与认知科学系的副教授，她致力于探索人类如何理解和产生语言。她利用脑成像和其他研究方法来研究健康个体、患有语言相关脑部疾病的人群以及超多语者。她感兴趣的问题包括：语言与其他认知能力之间有什么关系？我们能在没有语言的情况下思考吗？我们大脑中的语言系统是如何组织的？它在童年时期是如何形成的，又如何在人的一生中发生变化？
We'll try to touch on those topics today. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Federenko. It's my pleasure to be here. So, as I indicated, your research is much broader than hyper polyglotism. But let's start with that topic because it's so fascinating. How did you become interested in studying people who speak? dozens of languages and why does studying this extremely rare ability, why is this a useful way to learn more about language and the brain? As you know, for many years, centuries really, researchers have studied individuals with language problems.
我们今天将尝试探讨这些话题。感谢您加入我们，费德连科博士。很高兴能来到这里。正如我所提到的，您的研究范围远不止超多语现象。但让我们从这个话题开始，因为它太迷人了。您是如何对研究那些会说几十种语言的人产生兴趣的？为什么研究这种极其罕见的能力是了解语言和大脑的一种有效途径？如您所知，多年来，实际上是几个世纪以来，研究人员一直在研究有语言障碍的个体。
And the intuition there is very clear. We can learn a lot about how something works by looking at ways in which it can break hormonal function. And we have learned a lot from individuals with both developmental disorders like autism as well as acquired disorders like aphasia due to stroke or degeneration or head trauma or something like that. But there is this other extreme in any cognitive ability or perceptual ability you can think of. There's this extreme where it seems that some tail of the population, some small number of individuals in the population are especially good at something. And it's kind of interesting to think about what it means to be good at language, and there's probably many different ways in which you can be good at language. But it certainly seems that this ability to acquire multiple languages, multiple mappings between meanings and forms like words and constructions is certainly one way in which you can be good at language. And some people seem to have a propensity for this, or at least in one way or another, become hyperpholyglots. And so we get interested and maybe we can learn something about how the typical system works,
其中的直觉非常明确。我们可以通过观察事物如何发生功能障碍来了解其运作机制。我们从患有自闭症等发育障碍以及因中风、退行性疾病或头部创伤等导致的失语症等获得性障碍的个体身上学到了很多。但在任何认知能力或感知能力中，都存在另一个极端。在这个极端中，人口中的一小部分人似乎在某方面特别擅长。思考“擅长语言”意味着什么很有趣，而且擅长语言的方式可能有很多种。但毫无疑问，这种习得多种语言、在意义与形式（如单词和结构）之间建立多种映射的能力，确实是擅长语言的一种方式。有些人似乎天生就有这种倾向，或者以某种方式成为了超多语者。因此，我们产生了兴趣，也许我们可以借此了解典型系统是如何运作的，
but also studying this other extreme of linguistic abilities. Do we have any idea how rare hyper polyglotism is? And are there particular characteristics of hyper polyglot, such as, are they mostly men? Do they tend to be ambidextrous? I mean, what's unique about them in addition to their language ability? The prevalence is very hard to estimate. There are now a few of these organizations that try to kind of bring together polyglots, but I still think there's many people who kind of do this on their own. And
同时也研究这种语言能力的另一个极端。我们对超多语现象的罕见程度有概念吗？超多语者是否有特定的特征，比如他们大多是男性吗？他们是否倾向于左右手通用？除了语言能力之外，他们还有什么独特之处？这种普遍性很难估计。现在有一些组织试图将多语者聚集在一起，但我仍然认为有许多人是独自进行学习的。而且
Vaughn Smith, who recently was covered in the Washington Post article, is one of those people, right? That he just does it and nobody knows he doesn't belong to any societies or anything like that. So I think it's probably whatever estimates exist out there are probably underestimates. In terms of characteristics, it's a surprisingly heterogeneous population. One thing that seems to hold for many people is that, and this was counterintuitive to me, is that they're not typically individuals who grew up in multilingual societies. So there are some countries like, you know, the Netherlands where most kids grow up speaking three languages or Switzerland or, you know, parts of India. They typically grow up in relatively monolingual societies or societies where there's
最近在《华盛顿邮报》文章中提到的沃恩·史密斯就是其中之一，对吧？他只是自己学习，没人知道他，他也不属于任何协会之类的。所以我认为现有的任何估计可能都是低估了。就特征而言，这是一个令人惊讶的异质群体。有一点似乎适用于许多人，这对我来说是反直觉的，那就是他们通常不是在多语社会中长大的。所以，像荷兰、瑞士或印度部分地区，大多数孩子从小就说三种语言。他们通常是在相对单语的社会中长大的，或者是在
one dominant language, like Russia has a high proportion of polyglots. The U.S. does as well. So they grow up monolingual and then at some point they just get interested in learning languages and maybe start with like a typical class in school and then realize that they like doing this or are good at it and then just kind of keep going with this. But otherwise it's a very heterogeneous group of people. Some are really extroverted and can learn through kind of social interaction with native speakers. Some are quite introverted and learn primarily from books. It seems that the ways in which they're good at learning languages is also different. We can talk more about that. But yeah, I think more of the people that we've tested so far are males,
有一种主导语言的社会中长大的，比如俄罗斯就有很高比例的多语者。美国也是如此。所以他们从小是单语者，然后在某个时候对学习语言产生了兴趣，也许是从学校的一门典型课程开始，然后意识到自己喜欢这样做或者擅长这样做，然后就一直坚持下去了。但除此之外，这是一个非常异质的群体。有些人非常外向，可以通过与母语者的社交互动来学习。有些人则相当内向，主要通过书本学习。似乎他们擅长学习语言的方式也各不相同。我们可以多谈谈这一点。但是的，我认为到目前为止我们测试的人中男性更多，
but I would not attribute much to that just because historically in our society, males have had more encouragement for certain things. And I think there's still biases these days so that girls may be not as much encouraged or something like this. And so I would be very cautious in making any claims about gender biases until our society is healthy enough in terms of the lack of sexism when we can assess these things more fairly. Yes, we're waiting for that day. So much of your research uses fMRI brain imaging. What have you found when you look at the brains of hyper polyglots? How do their brains look or function differently compared with the brains of people who only speak one or two languages?
但我不会将其归因于太多因素，仅仅是因为在我们的社会历史上，男性在某些方面得到了更多的鼓励。我认为如今仍然存在偏见，导致女孩可能没有得到那么多的鼓励。因此，在我们的社会在消除性别歧视方面足够健康，能够更公平地评估这些事情之前，我对任何关于性别偏见的说法都会非常谨慎。是的，我们正在等待那一天。您的很多研究都使用了功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）脑成像。当您观察超多语者的大脑时，您发现了什么？与只会说一两种语言的人相比，他们的大脑在外观或功能上有什么不同？
So, of course, for this comparison, if we're comparing polyglots and typical individuals, we have to look at the responses at these participants' native language, right? Because otherwise, it's difficult to make comparisons because there will be differences in proficiency. But I can take you, your native speaker of English, and I can take a polyglot, whose native language is also. language, right? And if you look at the neural responses to native language, we find that in hyperpolyglots, the language system looks smaller than the typical individuals, meaning the amount of territory that kind of lights up, quote unquote, in the brain when they process language is smaller, and the regions that respond to language respond less strongly when they process language
当然，为了进行这种比较，如果我们比较多语者和典型个体，我们必须观察这些参与者母语的反应，对吧？因为否则很难进行比较，因为熟练程度会有所不同。但我可以拿你作为英语母语者，拿一个母语也是英语的多语者来比较。如果你观察母语的神经反应，我们发现超多语者的语言系统看起来比典型个体更小，这意味着当他们处理语言时，大脑中“点亮”的区域范围更小，而且当他们处理语言时，对语言做出反应的区域反应强度也更弱，
compared to you or me. And this was originally an accidental discovery. We had somebody contact us a bunch of years ago now and said, I have a son who is a polyblood, learning, you know, I had like 20 or something languages. Would you be interested in testing him? And, you know, I was young. I guess I'm still pretty young, but I was younger
与你或我相比。这最初是一个偶然的发现。几年前有人联系我们说：“我有一个儿子是多语者，学会了大约20种语言。你有兴趣测试他吗？”当时我很年轻。我想我现在还是很年轻，但我当时更年轻，
and very interested broadly in how language works in the brain. And so I said, yeah, sure. we had some extra resources at the time, and so we brought him out, and we scanned him on our usual paradigms. And lo and behold, his language regions look really wimpy. And I was like, that's strange. You might expect a priority, right, that somebody who is really good at language will have these robust, strongly responding areas. And the responses look small. And we tested them again the next stage to make sure things are replicable. And again, they look small. And I'm like, oh, that's, that's interesting. And then I started talking to other people working in different
并且对大脑如何运作语言非常感兴趣。所以我说：“好的，没问题。”当时我们有一些额外的资源，所以我们把他带过来，用我们通常的范式对他进行了扫描。结果发现，他的语言区域看起来真的很“弱”。我当时想，这很奇怪。你可能会先验地认为，一个真正擅长语言的人会有这些强大、反应强烈的区域。但反应看起来很小。我们在下一阶段再次测试了他们，以确保结果是可复制的。结果它们看起来还是很小。我想，哦，这很有趣。然后我开始与在不同领域工作的人交谈。
domains. And people brought up examples of motor learning. And they said, well, actually, that's kind of what happens when you learn new motor skills. So if I teach you some complicated motor skill, like some tracing of complex patterns or something, and I have you do it initially, you'll have big chunks of your motor cortex respond as you're still kind of getting better. And as you get more and more proficient, and it becomes kind of more automated, the amount of motor cortex that you have to recruit becomes smaller. So you don't need to use as much tissue to achieve the same level of performance. And so maybe something similar is happening here.
人们提到了运动学习的例子。他们说，嗯，实际上，当你学习新的运动技能时，情况就是这样。所以如果我教你一些复杂的运动技能，比如描摹复杂的图案之类的，我让你刚开始做的时候，当你还在进步时，你的运动皮层会有很大一部分做出反应。而当你变得越来越熟练，它变得越来越自动化时，你需要调动的运动皮层数量就会变小。所以你不需要使用那么多的组织来达到同样的表现水平。所以也许这里也发生了类似的事情。
So that's the parallel we drew in interpreting these results. Oh, yeah, and I should say that, you know, then eventually we kind of got other polyglots contact us. We found a few local ones at MIT in surrounding area. And so in the end we ended up with like a set of 20. that finding holds across them. So looking at the distribution of the sizes of the language areas in that population is definitely shifted to the smaller side compared to this large normative scent that we have now like hundreds of typical participants. So what else sets hyper polyglots apart? Are they generally extremely smart in other ways? Or is
这就是我们在解释这些结果时所做的类比。哦，是的，我应该说，后来我们又有一些多语者联系我们。我们在麻省理工学院及周边地区找到了一些当地的多语者。最终我们得到了大约20人的样本。这一发现对他们来说是成立的。因此，观察该群体中语言区域大小的分布，与我们现在拥有的数百名典型参与者的大型规范样本相比，肯定向较小的一侧偏移了。那么，还有什么让超多语者与众不同呢？他们在其他方面通常也非常聪明吗？还是
their talent just restricted to language? Do they have to study hard to learn languages in the that other adults do or does it come more easily and naturally to them the way that it might to children? In the study that in the one study we published on the neural responses to native language in polyglots and typical individuals, we actually matched for IQ. So the difference that we observed holds in spite of similar levels of kind of general fluid intelligence. We also looked at the responses, neural responses in the brain system that kind of supports
他们的天赋仅限于语言？他们必须像其他成年人一样努力学习语言，还是像孩子那样更容易、更自然地掌握？在我们发表的关于多语者和典型个体对母语神经反应的研究中，我们实际上匹配了智商。因此，尽管一般流体智力水平相似，但我们观察到的差异仍然存在。我们还观察了支持一般流体推理的大脑系统中的神经反应，这些区域的大小看起来相似。所以并不是说无论你看哪个系统，他们整个大脑都很高效，这似乎是语言特有的。总的来说，我们和其他人发现这两个系统是相当独立的，即支持思考和推理的系统与支持语言处理的系统。但就让他们与众不同的原因而言，我认为我们还不太清楚。不可否认，有些人学习语言确实比其他人更容易。
general fluid reasoning and those regions look similar in size. So it's not like their whole brain is efficient, no matter what system you look at, it seems specific to language. And in general, we and others have found that those two systems are quite separate, the system that supports thinking and reasoning and the system that supports language processing. But in terms of what makes them different, I don't think we know quite yet. So it's undeniable that there are some people for whom learning languages is easier than others.
这种差异性是存在的。我自己学过很多语言，直到我搬到美国。它们都变得有点沉寂并被遗忘了。但在成长过程中，我学过。我喜欢这样做，而且很容易。就像，我喜欢这样做，而且它似乎很自然。我可以轻松记住事物。我可以破译语法模式。
That just that variability is there. I myself learned a lot of languages until I moved to the U.S. And it all got kind of dormant and forgotten. But growing up, I learned it. And I loved doing it and it was easy. Like, I enjoyed doing it and it kind of came naturally. I could remember things easily. I could decipher grammatical patterns.
所以，你会听到其他人谈论它。他们会说，是的，似乎我很快就能对一门语言有很好的感觉。就像我学了几个单词后，就能理解哪些单词相关，构建句子比我的同龄人在同样的环境下学习时要容易得多。但同样令人惊讶的是，也有一些超多语者非常坚持认为他们没有任何特殊天赋。同样，也许内省并不是最好的方法，但他们只是说，我只是喜欢这样做。这对我来说就像一种爱好。我花了很多时间做这件事。
So, and you'll hear other people talk about it. And they're like, yeah, it seems like I get like a good feel for a language very quickly. Like I can kind of understand which words I relate and construct things once I learn a few words, construct things much more easily than my peers seem to they're learning me in the same environment or something like that. But there's also, again, quite surprising that there's also hyperpolybloods who are pretty adamant that they don't have any special talent. Again, maybe introspection is not the best way to, but they just say, I just like doing it. It's like a, it's like a hobby for me. I spend a lot of time doing this.
我变得更好了，但我并不认为我在语言上有什么天赋。我只是花了很多时间。比如，我每天花20分钟，或者每周花一小时在我的20或30种语言中的每一种上。我变得擅长是因为人们通过练习变得擅长，对吧？就像，几乎任何人通过练习几乎任何任务都会变得擅长。但是，当然，存在这种潜在的差异性。而且有可能一些更极端的超多语者在20多种语言上达到熟练程度，
and I get better, but I don't think I'm linguistically gifted in any way. I just kind of spend a lot of time. Like, I spend, you know, 20 minutes each day or whatever, you know, an hour a week on each of my 20 or 30 languages. And I get good because people get good with practice, right? Like, anybody will get good. Almost anybody will get good with practice on almost any task. But, of course, there is this underlying variability. And it's possible that some of the kind of more extreme hyperpolyglots who achieve proficiency
也许是某种天生天赋的结合，如果你愿意的话。人们有时会对使用这样的术语感到不安，但，你知道，无论如何，天生擅长语言的倾向，无论是什么，加上大量的练习。然后也许把这些东西结合起来。你就可以达到那种学习意义和形式之间如此多不同映射的能力的真正极端。
in upward of 20 languages, maybe it's some combination of some innate talent, if you wish. People sometimes get upset about the use of terms like that, but, you know, whatever, innate biases to be good at language, whatever, and a lot of practice. And then maybe combine those things together. You can kind of get to the real extreme of that ability to learn so many different mappings between meanings and forms.
但我认为我们还有很多不了解的地方。这是一个研究不足的群体。他们人数不多，而且他们也不是都集中在一个地区之类的。所以这是一个非常有挑战性的研究群体。但我希望我们最近所做的一些工作能激励其他人尝试更广泛地以各种其他方式来描述他们，而不仅仅是你的反应。所以我认为在准备与您交谈时，有趣的是，在音乐能力和语言能力之间似乎没有联系？因为你会认为有些语言是非常有声调的，它们听起来几乎像音乐。然而却没有联系。您是否了解为什么会这样？这看起来很反直觉。为了澄清这种缺乏，语言和音乐之间的分离发生在语言理解的层面上。
But I think there's a lot we don't have. understand this is a very understudied population. There's not many of them, and they're not like all in one area or something. So it's a pretty challenging group to study. But I'm hoping that some of the stuff we've been doing recently will inspire others to try to characterize them kind of more broadly and in all sorts of other ways, aside from just your responses. So I thought it was interesting in preparing to talk to you that there isn't a connection
所以你用来理解和产生语言的系统，即从单词序列中推断意义并将你的思想转化为单词序列的系统，与音乐是完全分开的。这与许多提议相反。我认为，现在我们和其他几个小组有强有力的证据表明，当你听音乐时，语言区域根本没有工作，即使它很复杂、结构化，并且具有人们争论的可能在音乐和语言之间共享的各种属性。但在较低水平的听觉处理上确实有一些重叠。
between, say, musical ability and language ability? Because you would think there are some languages that are very tonal and they almost sound like music. And yet there isn't a connection. Do you have any understanding of why that might be? It just seems counterintuitive. To clarify the lack of, so the dissociation between language and music is happening at the level of kind of language understanding.
例如，我们听觉皮层的一部分关心音高声音。所以任何种类的音高声音，它可以是火车喇叭、语音片段或一段音乐。只要有音高调制、谐波存在，该区域就会活跃。因此，通过这种共享的机制，确实存在一些迁移效应，例如音乐家学习声调语言更容易。这些效应已经被报道了很长一段时间。成为一名音乐家，即拥有大量的音乐练习，或者具有音乐天赋，或者拥有绝对音高之类的东西，似乎并不能让你在学习语言方面变得更好，但它会有助于语言中依赖于你正在训练的那种能力的方面，即注意信号中的音高，但这看起来不像是一个普遍的事情。科学家们知道为什么婴儿和儿童能如此容易地学习语言，而随着年龄增长变得更加困难吗？我相信让小婴儿进入fMRI机器对您来说很难，但我知道您观察过一些孩子。是的，这是一个价值百万美元的问题，目前仍有很大争议。所以当你小时候学习语言和成年后学习语言时，很多事情都变了。首先，当你来到这个世界时，你对世界一无所知，对吧？所以与此同时，当你开始接触语音时，你也在学习
So the system that you use to understand and produce language, so to kind of infer meanings from sequences of words and convert your thoughts into sequences of words, that system is totally separate from music. And this is contra many proposals. And that is now, I think, we and a few other groups have strong evidence that the language regions are just not working at all when you're listening to music, even if it's complex and structured and has all sorts of properties that people argue maybe shared between music and language. But there is some overlap at the lower level auditory processing.
关于世界、世界上的社会代理人、世界的物理属性、物体、它们如何相互作用的各种事情。与此同时，你正在听到语言信号，或者如果你是一个学习手语的婴儿，你正在观察它们。然后，在某个时候，作为婴儿，你开始注意到有一些非随机性，比如每次你爸爸说“球”时，周围似乎都有这个圆圆的东西，对吧？嗯，你不知道“圆”这个词，但你大概知道有一个看起来像这个圆圆的东西，最终，我认为婴儿一定会有所领悟，
So there is, for example, a part of our auditory cortex that cares about pitched sounds. So any kind of pitch sounds, it can be a train horn or a speech segment or a piece of music. And anytime there is kind of pitch modulation, harmonics present, that region is active. And so through that shared machinery, there are indeed some transfer effects so that musicians, for example, have an easier time learning tonal languages. those effects have been reported for quite a while. It doesn't seem that being a musician, so having a lot of practice with music or being musically talented or having things like absolute pitch makes you better at learning languages in general, but it will help with the aspects of language that rely on that ability that
即我们用嘴巴发出的声音，或者如果我们是手语者，用手做出的动作，与环境之间存在这种非平凡的对应关系。一旦领悟了这一点，那么我认为，语言能力就会突飞猛进。词汇学习发生了，最终他们开始组合单词，以此类推。为什么我们失去了如此容易学习语言的能力，正如我所说，争议很大。首先，你已经有了一套映射，对吧？你已经学会了一门语言。所以那里已经有一个固定的映射系统。
you're training up, which is paying attention to pitch in the signal, but it doesn't see like a general thing. Why is it, do scientists know why babies and children can learn language so easily and that it becomes more difficult as we get older? I'm sure it's hard for you to get little babies and put them in fMRI machines, but I know you've looked at some kids. Yeah, that's a million dollar question that is still very much debated. So a lot of things change when you're learning a language as a kid and you're learning a language as an adult. So for one, when you come into the world, you don't know anything about the world, right? So at the same time, as you get it's starting to get exposure to speech, you're also learning
因此，在那个系统之上学习另一个映射系统可能会更难。我总是提出这一点，但我没看到其他人像我一样关注。但你学习第二语言的方式通常是非常非常不同的。因为我们实际上没有关于第一语言和后来习得语言的类似环境的控制良好的实验。因为，你知道，如果你有孩子，我有一个四岁的孩子，所以我们刚刚经历了整个语言学习过程。如果你是一个婴儿，每次你醒着的时候，你面前都有一张脸，它在对你发出语音。对吧？而且它爱你。
all sorts of things about the world, the social agents in the world, the physical properties of the world, the objects, how they interact. And at the same time, you're hearing linguistic signals or watching them if you're a baby learning sign language. And then at some point, you're, you know, as a baby, you start noticing that there's some non-randomness so that like every time you know your daddy says ball there seems to be this round thing around right well you don't know the word for round but you kind of know just that there's a thing like that looks like this round thing around and eventually i think it must click for babies
就像你周围所有这些照顾者，他们爱你，并且在你醒着的每次时候都与你互动。几乎每次你醒着的时候，都有某种语言。这与上课的体验非常不同。即使在沉浸式环境中，对吧？你可能会去巴黎。你坐在咖啡馆里。偶尔有人会和你说话。但并不是说你一直有爱你的人
that there is this non-trivial correspondence between these things that we're making the sounds that we're making with our mouths or with our hands if we're a signer um and the environment And then once that clicks, then I think, you know, like language just kind of goes through the roof. And word learning happens and eventually they start composing words and so on and so forth. Why we lose the ability to learn language as easily, like I said, very debated. So for one, you already have a set of mappings, right? You've learned a language. So there's already a fixed system there of how things map.
试图教你这项技能，以便我们能更好地互动，对吧？这只是一个非常不同、控制得很差的比较。并且有一些说法认为，早期不发达的执行能力可能是有帮助的，可能在后期会产生干扰。有一些说法认为婴儿最初没有这种倾向。所以语音是连续的，如果我们谈论口语，对吧？单词之间没有界限。所以孩子们会听到连续的语音片段，有时是相当大的片段。
So learning a system on top of that, another set of mapping on top of that may be harder. I always make this point that I haven't heard others focus on as much. But the way that you learn a second language is typically very, very different. So we actually don't have very well-controlled experiments of similar environments for first and later acquired languages. Because, you know, if you've had kids, I have a four-year-old, so we just went through this whole language learning thing. if you're a baby, every time you're awake, there's a face in front of your face and it's making speech sounds at you. Right? Like, and it loves you.
他们不知道该片段内的单词界限在哪里。以色列的因巴尔·阿农（Inbal Arnon）等人认为，实际上，不总是将事物解析为单个单词可能有助于你最初引导系统，因为你正在学习更大的片段，从中你可以潜在地更容易地推断出多词关系之类的东西。因为一旦你学习了，一旦你长大了，你就理解单词了，对吧？你知道有单词。所以当你学习第二语言时，
Like all these caregivers around you, they love you and they interact with you every time you're awake. Like pretty much every time you're awake, there is some kind of language. It's a very different experience from taking a class. And even in immersion, right? Like you may go to Paris. You're sitting in a cafe. Somebody will occasionally talk to you. But it's not like you're constantly having people who love you.
你学习的是单个单词，而不是像关注短语和结构那样，你可能会受益于某些单词序列总是同时出现的事实。所以外面有各种各样的假设。就证据而言，确实存在的大规模研究确实表明，你的语言学习能力在青春期之后，大约15、16岁左右，即青春期后期，会下降。但同样，只有一些能力受到影响。所以语法和感觉运动方面，比如口音，口音是在那个时间段之后很难失去的东西。就学习单词而言，无论你多大，你都可以继续学习单词。是的，这就是我们所处的位置。所以还有很多工作要做。由Newport Healthcare赞助，致力于为受心理健康问题困扰的年轻人提供可持续的康复，使他们能够从自我毁灭走向自尊。基于同情心并以结果为导向，
try to teach you the skill so that we can interact better, right? It's just a very different, it's a very bad, poorly controlled comparison. And there are some claims that underdeveloped executive abilities early on may be helpful, that maybe interfere later on. There is some claims that babies initially don't have the propensity. So speech is a continuous if we're talking about spoken language, right? there's no boundaries between words. And so kids will kind of hear continuous chunks of speech, sometimes in pretty large chunks.
Newport在全国各地的住院和门诊项目中为12至28岁的青少年和年轻人提供服务。通过量身定制的治疗和家庭支持，Newport成功解决了心理和行为健康问题，包括抑郁、焦虑、创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）、人格障碍和药物滥用。详情请访问Newporthealthcare.com。那么，转向一个稍微不同的方向，您还研究患有大脑异常的人，人们可能会认为这会损害他们的语言能力。例如，您最近发表了一篇关于一名缺失左颞叶的女性的论文，然而她却几乎没有受到影响。她的语言能力完全正常，甚至在某些方面表现出色，因为她能流利地说第二语言。那么像这样的案例研究
They don't know how the word boundaries are within that chunk. And people like in Bal Arnon in Israel has argued that actually not always parsing things into individual words may help you initially bootstrap the system because you're learning bigger chunks from which you can potentially more easily infer. kind of multi-word relationships and things like that. Because once you're learning, once you're grown up, you understand words, right? You understand that there's words. And so when you're learning a second language,
告诉我们关于大脑如何处理语言的信息？是的。所以这也是另一条工作线，它有点偶然地出现，因为这个人联系了我们并自愿贡献了她的大脑。直到她20多岁时偶然发现，她才知道自己的大脑有什么不同。事实证明，拥有一个不寻常的大脑实际上并不像你想象的那么罕见。因为我们的大脑有很多冗余和可塑性，特别是在早期，很多早期损伤都没有被发现。所以，当你通过产道或此后不久，你的大脑可能会发生一些重大事件。
you learn everything in individual words as opposed to paying attention to like phrases and constructions where you may benefit from the fact that a certain sequence of words always happens together. So there's all sorts of hypotheses out there. In terms of the evidence, kind of the largest scale studies that do exist, do suggest that there is a drop in your ability to learn languages in a native-like way
而你有足够的大脑组织来运作，所以你长大后完全正常。有时人们会快乐地生活，不知道自己大脑中缺失了一大块，因为他们没有任何症状。这意味着他们不会去看医生，也不会被转诊给神经科医生之类的。还有来自手术干预的证据，有时在早期针对例如严重癫痫的病例进行，我不认为他们现在还会做那么严重的手术，但过去有时会切除整个半球。
after around puberty like 15, 16 kind of late puberty. But again, there's only some abilities that are affected. So grammar and sensory motor stuff, so accents, accent is something that's really hard to lose after that time period. In terms of learning words, you can kind of keep learning words no matter how old you are. Right. Yeah, so that's where we are. So still a lot of work to be done. Sponsored by Newport Healthcare, dedicated to providing sustainable healing for young people struggling with mental health concerns so they can move from self-destruction to self-esteem. Based in compassion and driven by outcomes,
所以大脑半球切除术是过去常做的一种手术。同样，如果手术做得足够早，那些孩子长大后相对来说很好。有时他们会有一些运动缺陷。但在认知方面，一切似乎都还可以。当然，这与晚年发生中风或晚年进行切除部分语言皮层的手术形成鲜明对比，后者会导致问题。
Newport serves teens and young adults ages 12 to 28 at residential and outpatient programs nationwide. through tailored treatment and family support, Newport successfully addresses psychological and behavioral health issues, including depression, anxiety, PTSD, personality disorders, and substance abuse. Learn more at Newporthealthcare.com. So going in a slightly different direction, you also study people with brain abnormalities that people might think would hurt their language abilities. For instance, you recently published a paper about a woman who is missing her left temporal lobe, and yet she's remarkably unaffected by it. She has totally normal language abilities, even exceptional in some ways because she speaks a second language fluently. So what do case studies
我认为你可以从这个群体中学到很多不同的东西。所以我们发表的这篇论文，我们提出了一个你甚至无法以任何其他方式真正提出的问题。我们询问了语言系统是否由颞叶和额叶区域组成。额叶皮层，就像在你头的前部和侧面，颞叶的侧颞侧。通常我们尽早测量就能看到它们。正如你所说，很难把孩子放进扫描仪里。所以你从四五岁左右开始就能做得很好。在这个年龄，如果你观察他们的语言区域，他们有颞叶区域
like that tell us about how language is processed in the brain? Yes. So this is also another line of work that kind of came about somewhat accidentally because this individual reached out to us and volunteered her brain. So she didn't know that anything was different about her brain until she was in her 20s and she kind of accidentally found out. And it turns out that it's actually not so uncommon as you might think to have an unusual brain. Because our brains have a lot of redundancy and plasticity, especially early on, a lot of early damage goes undetected. So, some big event may happen in your brain as you're going through the birth canal or shortly thereafter.
他们有额叶区域。问题是，它们之间的关系是什么？有些区域是否出现得更早，额叶区域是否出现得更晚，因为也有很多证据表明额叶总体发育较慢。所以这个在没有颞叶、左颞叶的情况下长大的个体，可以让我们问，她那完全健康的左额叶皮层中会有对语言的神经反应吗？那里正在发生很多其他事情。所以她大脑的那部分会有一些语言反应吗？
And you have so much brain tissue to work with that you grow up totally normal. Sometimes people kind of live their life happily and don't know that they have some big chunk of their brain missing because they don't have any symptoms. And that means they don't go to a doctor and they don't get referred to a neurologist or anything like that. There is also evidence from surgical interventions that sometimes are done early on for cases of, for example, severe epilepsy, where I don't think they do that quite anymore as severe, but it used to be the case that sometimes whole hemispheres would be removed.
结果是没有。所以她的语言系统完全重映射到了她的右半球。我不应该说重映射，因为也有人声称语言最初是双侧的，早期是双侧的，然后随着你的成长变得更加侧向化，尽管这也存在争议。但无论如何，她的语言系统愉快地生活在她的右半球。但与典型个体不同的是，比如，如果我把你放进扫描仪，你的语言区域很可能在左侧。但你也会在右侧同位对应区域有一些反应。这有点像你通常看到的。而在脑电图（EG）中，无论我们使用的测试检测语言反应的能力有多强，这个没有左颞叶的个体，在她完全健康的左额叶皮层中，对语言的反应为零，这表明也许正是这种颞叶皮层的缺失导致了这些区域没有出现，对吧？
So hemispherectomy is a surgery that used to be done. And again, those kids, if the surgery is done early enough, they grow up and they're relatively fine. Sometimes they'll have some motor deficits. But in terms of their cognition, everything seems okay. Now, of course, this is in striking contrast to having a stress. stroke later in life or having a surgical procedure that removes some part of your language cortex later in life, which will lead to problems.
所以也许你需要这些颞叶到额叶的连接来在早期连接语言系统的额叶部分。但自从这个词被媒体报道以来，很多人写信给我说：“你知道，我也有一个不寻常的大脑。”然后会给我发他们的核磁共振截图，他们缺失了右颞叶
And I think you can learn a lot of different things from this population. So this paper we published, we asked the question that you couldn't even really ask in any other way. We asked about whether, so the language system consists of temporal and frontal areas. The frontal cortic layers, like in the front of your head and side of your head, lateral temporal side of the temporal lobe. And typically we see them both as early as can be measured. As you said, it's hard to put kids in the scanner. So you can do it from about four or five pretty well. At that age, if you look at their language regions, they have the temporal regions
或者缺失了额叶皮层块，或者缺失了顶叶。因此，我认为我们可以在这个群体中非常有趣地解决的一个问题是语言和社会认知之间的关系。所以语言，正如我们提到的，通常在左半球，在左半球表现得更强，而各种社会功能在右半球表现得更强。现在，如果你只有大脑的一侧，或者很大程度上，你知道，如果大脑的一侧缺失了很多，那么社会认知的一些部分就必须移动到左侧
and they have the frontal regions. The question is, what is the relationship between them? Do some of them emerge earlier than do the frontal regions emerge later because there is also a lot of evidence that frontal lobes in general are slower developing. And so this individual who grew up without her temporal lobe, left temporal lobe, could allow us to ask, would there be responses, neural responses to language in her left frontal cortex, which is perfectly healthy? A lot of other stuff is happening there. So would there be some language responses in that part of her brain?
或者语言的一些部分就必须移动到右侧。我们想了解这两个系统如何在同一个半球内共存的约束。比如，它们可以开始共享资源吗？它们真的可以招募大脑中重叠的部分，并且仍然表现为典型的认知，在语言或社会处理方面没有缺陷吗？还是它们只是占据更少的空间并保持完全隔离？或者在这些情况下它们如何重组？这就是我们这项工作的方向。所以当你观察EG时，那个缺失左颞叶的女性，她有社会缺陷吗？
Then there isn't. So her language system was totally remapped onto her right hemisphere. I shouldn't say remapped because there was also a claim that language is originally bilateral, early on bilateral, and then it becomes more lateralized as you grow up, although that's also controversial. But in any case, her language system is happily living in her right hemisphere. But unlike in typical individuals where, say, if I put you in the scanner, you likely will have your language areas in the left. But you'll also have some responses in the right homotopic corresponding areas. That's kind of what you typically see. And in EG, no matter how much this is this individual without her left temporal lobe, no matter how powerful the tests were that we were using to detect language responses, there's just zero response to language anywhere in her perfectly healthy left frontal lobe, suggesting that perhaps the lack of this temporal cortex is what's making these regions not emerge, right?
你在寻找那个吗？她没有。我的意思是，我们已经在一些基本的东西上测试了她，我们甚至在所谓的语用任务的相当广泛的电池测试中测试了她。所以这些能力处于语言和社会认知的交汇处，比如理解讽刺，或者理解当某人在问你问题时，但实际上他们想让你做某事。对吧？如果我说，“你能把盐递给我吗？”我并不是真的在问你是否能做到。我是在让你去做。这就是我们这样做的方式。是的。她在这一点上看起来完全典型，或者像使用对比韵律之类的东西，对吧？比如如果我
So maybe you need these temporal to frontal connections early on to kind of wire up the frontal parts of the language system. But ever since this word got covered by the media, I've had a lot of people write to me and say, you know, I also have an unusual brain and that will send me like screenshots of their MRIs and they have like their right temporal lobe missing
强调我信息的一部分来表明某事与你可能认为的不同，比如，“不，我想要一件红色的裙子，”对吧？暗示也许我们之前在谈论一件蓝色的裙子，而我正在对比这一点。所以这些处于理解人们心理状态（如意图）交汇处的线索，比如，“为什么他们这么说？”“为什么他们以这种方式说？”以及语言处理在她身上似乎完全完整。我想我们也许可以看更多的东西，但她确实是一个令人愉快的人。
or their frontal cortex chunks missing or their friatal lobe missing. And so one question that I think we can very interestingly address in this population is the relationship between language and social cognition. So language, as we mentioned, is typically in the left hemisphere, present more strongly in the left hemisphere, and all sorts of social functions are more strongly present in the right hemisphere. Now, if you only have one side of your brain, or largely, you know, if a lot of the brain is missing on one side, some parts of the, say, social cognition would have to move to the left
而且，我们现在已经与她互动了，我想，三次。你知道，你永远不会怀疑她的大脑有什么不同。所以这也告诉你，我们不需要我们拥有的那么多大脑。对吧。当然，如果不是这样的话，外科医生就会失业了，对吧？他们会告诉你，有很多东西你可以切除，即使在成年人身上，我们也完全没问题。你观察的一个问题，我也觉得非常迷人，是语言和思想之间的关系
or some parts of language would have to move to the right. And we want to understand the constraints on how these two systems can coexist within the same hemisphere. Like, can they start sharing resources? Can they actually recruit overlapping bits of the brain and still manifest as typical cognition with no deficits in either language or social processing? Or do they just take up less space and remain fully segregated? Or how do they reorganize in such cases? So that's where we're going with that work. So when you looked at EG, the woman with the missing temporal left temporal lobe, did she have social deficits?
对于许多人来说，直觉上似乎如果你没有语言，你就无法进行复杂的思考，但您发现情况并非一定如此。您能解释一下如何在没有语言的情况下进行思考吗？我认为关于我们自己思维过程的直觉有其局限性。我们可能对我们如何思考有一些直觉，但实际上我认为经验数据更有说服力。所以这个关于你是否需要语言来思考复杂思想的问题是一个非常大且深刻的问题。历史上有一种非常强烈的倾向将它们联系在一起。因为基本上它是这样说的：“哦，你知道，这里有一种动物。”
Were you looking for that? She doesn't. I mean, we've tested her on some basic stuff, and we even tested her in a pretty extensive battery of so-called pragmatic tasks. So these are abilities that are kind of at the junction of language and social cognition, so understanding sarcasm or understanding when somebody is asking your question, but really they want you to do something. right? If I say, can you please best the salt? I'm not really asking you if you can do it. I'm asking you to do it. That's just the way we do this. Yes. And she looks absolutely typical on this, you know, or like also things like using contrast of prosody, right? Like if I'm
你在找那个吗？她没有。我的意思是，我们对她进行了一些基础测试，甚至还让她完成了一系列相当广泛的所谓语用任务。这些能力处于语言和社交认知的交汇点，比如理解讽刺，或者理解当某人问你问题时，其实是想让你做某事。对吧？如果我说，你能把盐递给我吗？我并不是真的在问你能不能做到，我是在要求你去做。我们就是这样交流的。是的。在这方面，她看起来完全正常，还有像使用对比韵律之类的事情，对吧？比如如果我
emphasizing a sort of part of my message to indicate that something is different from what you might have thought, like, no, I want a red dress, right? Suggesting that maybe we were talking about a blue dress before and I'm contrasting this. So these kinds of cues that are at the junction of understanding people's mental states, like intense, like, why are they saying it? Like, why are they saying it in this way? And linguistic processing seemed totally intact at her. I think we can maybe look at more stuff, but really she's like a delightful person.
强调我信息中的某一部分，以表明某事与你可能认为的不同，比如，不，我想要一件红色的裙子，对吧？暗示我们之前可能在谈论一件蓝色的裙子，而我正在进行对比。所以这些处于理解他人心理状态（如意图）交汇点的线索，比如，他们为什么要这么说？他们为什么要用这种方式说？她的语言处理能力看起来完全完好。我想我们或许可以研究更多东西，但她确实是一个令人愉快的人。
And, you know, we've now interacted with her for, she's come out, I think, three times. and you know, you would never suspect that anything is different about her brain. So it also tells you that we don't need as much brain as we have. Right. And of course, the surgeons would be out of jobs if that wasn't the case, right? They'll tell you that there's a lot of stuff you can cut out, and even in adults, and we're totally fine. One question you look at that I find really fascinating also is the relationship between language and thought
而且，你知道，我们现在已经和她互动过，我想她来过三次。你知道，你永远不会怀疑她的大脑有什么不同。所以这也告诉你，我们并不需要像现在拥有的一样多的大脑。对吧。当然，如果不是这样的话，外科医生就会失业了，对吧？他们会告诉你，有很多东西是可以切除的，即使是在成年人身上，我们也完全没问题。你研究的一个问题我觉得也非常迷人，那就是语言和思维之间的关系
and for many people, it seems intuitive that you couldn't engage in complex thinking if you didn't have language, but you've found that's not necessarily the case. Can you explain how you can have thought without language? I think intuitions about our own thinking processes have their limitations. We may have some intuitions about how we think, but really I think empirical data are more compelling. And so this question of whether you need language to think complex thoughts is a really big and deep one. And there is a very strong propensity historically to link them together. Because basically the way it goes as, oh, you know, here is a species of animals.
对许多人来说，直觉上认为如果没有语言，你就无法进行复杂的思考，但你发现情况并非一定如此。你能解释一下如何在没有语言的情况下进行思考吗？我认为关于我们自身思维过程的直觉是有局限性的。我们可能对我们如何思考有一些直觉，但我认为实证数据更具说服力。所以，是否需要语言才能进行复杂思考，这是一个非常宏大且深刻的问题。历史上有一种非常强烈的倾向将两者联系在一起。因为基本上它的逻辑是，哦，你知道，这是一种动物。
Right. Humans. They're really smart and they have language. Therefore, they're smart because they have language. And that logically just doesn't follow at all. it could be that they got smart, they got smarter than other animals, and then the communication system kind of caught up. Once you have enough mental complexity, enough complexity in your thoughts that you want to share them,
对。人类。他们确实很聪明，而且拥有语言。因此，他们聪明是因为他们拥有语言。从逻辑上讲，这根本站不住脚。可能是他们先变得聪明，比其他动物更聪明，然后交流系统才随之跟上。一旦你有了足够的心理复杂性，有了足够复杂的想法想要分享，
maybe you then come up with a more sophisticated code so that you can share your thoughts with one another. But in terms of evidence, yes, it seems that the language system is relatively silent as measured with tools like FMRI, when you engage in playing chess, solving problems, doing math, all sorts of things that you would think would be closely linked to language or relying on linguistic representations and in individuals with severe aphasia,
也许你就会想出一种更复杂的代码，以便与他人分享你的想法。但就证据而言，是的，当你在下棋、解决问题、做数学题或进行各种你认为与语言密切相关或依赖语言表征的活动时，使用功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）等工具测量发现，语言系统似乎相对静默。而在患有严重失语症的个体中，
so severe language problems, you can ask them to do all sorts of things and short of translating them into language, like understanding language or producing language, they can do everything that you and I can do. They can navigate the world. They can understand others' intentions, as long as you don't have to rely on the verbal cues, right? You can infer it from people's behaviors, actions, facial expressions and things like that. They can do Sudoku puzzles. I mean, they can basically, they have the same richness of their mental worlds as they did before they had this major stroke event. They just lose the ability to
也就是有严重语言障碍的人，你可以要求他们做各种事情，除了需要将其转化为语言的事情，比如理解语言或产生语言，他们能做你我能做的所有事情。他们可以导航世界。他们可以理解他人的意图，只要你不依赖语言线索，对吧？你可以从人们的行为、动作、面部表情等推断出来。他们可以做数独游戏。我的意思是，他们基本上拥有和中风前一样丰富的内心世界。他们只是失去了将这些想法
convert those thoughts into a code that other humans can understand. But they have language, right? I mean, they could speak before the stroke, so they actually have language, as opposed to, say, like the Helen Keller test, right, where she was, you know, a little girl before she actually got language as we understand it. That's right. So the question is they're like, was it necessary for language to be there early on to get some of these capacities to develop? And that's an interesting question because, of course, in these adult stroke cases, you know, everything was they had both language and they had their mentally, you know, general intelligence. And then at some point, the language system was basically taken out and the rest of cognition seems okay. But maybe if you don't have access to language early on, you can't actually develop the ability to, you know, categorize things in the world or do math or something like that. And of course, it's much harder to ask that question because you can't deprive kids.
转化为其他人能理解的代码的能力。但他们拥有语言，对吧？我的意思是，他们在脑卒中前会说话，所以他们实际上拥有语言，这与海伦·凯勒测试不同，对吧？她在真正掌握我们所理解的语言之前只是个小女孩。没错。所以问题在于，语言在早期是否必须存在才能让这些能力发展起来？这是一个有趣的问题，因为当然，在这些成人中风病例中，他们既有语言能力，也有一般的智力。然后在某个时刻，语言系统基本上被切断了，而其余的认知功能似乎还可以。但也许如果你在早期没有接触过语言，你就无法真正发展出对世界进行分类、做数学题等能力。当然，要问这个问题要困难得多，因为你不能剥夺孩子们的语言。
of language, but there are cases where deaf kids are born to hearing parents, which is actually the majority of deaf kids, are born to hearing parents. And so their parents don't know sign language because they typically wouldn't have had a reason to learn sign language. And in some such cases, these kids don't get access to language for sometimes a few years, sometimes into their teenage years. It hardly ever happens in the US anymore because of all the education about deafness and the importance of sign language.
但有些聋哑孩子出生在听力正常的父母家庭中，实际上大多数聋哑孩子都是这样。所以他们的父母不懂手语，因为他们通常没有理由去学习手语。在某些情况下，这些孩子有时几年，甚至到十几岁都没有接触过语言。在美国，由于关于耳聋和手语重要性的教育普及，这种情况几乎不再发生了。
From the anecdotal evidence and some sparse experimental evidence that exists, it seems that again most things you can learn without language, not that it, you know, not that it wouldn't be easier if you had language, but it's not like you can't learn math absent linguistic input. And I think there's more work to be done on that. I think it's a very exciting population that can shed light on this question, but there's only a handful of individuals who really were lacking language for a long enough time that it would have mattered. But I'm trying to team up with a researcher at BU to try to look at this more systematically. Another area where you're doing research is on artificial intelligence language learning systems.
从轶事证据和现有的少量实验证据来看，似乎大多数事情你都可以在没有语言的情况下学习，并不是说如果你有语言不会更容易，但并不是说没有语言输入你就不能学习数学。我认为这方面还有更多工作要做。我认为这是一个非常令人兴奋的人群，可以阐明这个问题，但真正长期缺乏语言以至于产生影响的个体只有少数。但我正试图与波士顿大学的一位研究人员合作，尝试更系统地研究这个问题。你正在研究的另一个领域是人工智能语言学习系统。
Do AI language systems learn language the same way that humans do? Almost certainly not. I mean, they're basically, they have a bunch of text. jumped on them, right? That's not at all like we were saying, you know, the way a baby learns is very, very different. I mean, and there's many ways in which it's different. Like, one, you just get linguistic input and it's completely unrelated from the perceptual and motor experiences in the world, right? They just have sequences of words as all they're being fed, the models. And of course, they also don't have any social interactive component, right? There's no way they can understand intent. behind why somebody might say something. All they get are co-corrences among words. Now, with a large enough training set, you can get a lot from those co-currences. Language is very powerful in that it reflects all sorts of regularities about the world. And so in some cases, if you have a model generates some coherent text, it's very tempting to think that the model knows something, quote, unquote.
人工智能语言系统学习语言的方式和人类一样吗？几乎肯定不是。我的意思是，它们基本上是被灌输了大量文本，对吧？这和我们所说的完全不同，你知道，婴儿学习的方式非常非常不同。我的意思是，它在很多方面都不同。比如，第一，你只是获得语言输入，它与世界上的感知和运动经验完全无关，对吧？这些模型被喂食的只是单词序列。当然，它们也没有任何社会互动成分，对吧？它们无法理解某人说某话背后的意图。它们得到的只是单词之间的共现。现在，有了足够大的训练集，你可以从这些共现中获得很多东西。语言非常强大，因为它反映了关于世界的各种规律。因此，在某些情况下，如果一个模型生成了一些连贯的文本，人们很容易认为该模型“知道”某些东西。
But of course, it doesn't really, all it knows is linguistic regularities. and it so happens that they reflect some world knowledge, but it's all restricted to the knowledge of language. The fact that they learn differently doesn't mean that they can be useful as models of some aspects of language processing behaviorally or in the brain. But I think all of these caveats need to be taken into account. For me, like we just talked about how language is separate from thinking. For us, for my group, I think these models are really,
但当然，它并不真正知道，它所知道的只是语言规律。碰巧这些规律反映了一些世界知识，但它们都局限于语言知识。它们学习方式的不同并不意味着它们不能作为语言处理行为或大脑层面的模型。但我认为所有这些注意事项都需要考虑在内。对我来说，就像我们刚才谈到的语言如何独立于思维一样。对于我们，对于我的团队，我认为这些模型确实
great because they're kind of like a clean version of language. It's like language in a box. None of the other stuff, perceptual, motor, conceptual is in there, right? It's just linguistic statistics, which is what I think the human language system is maybe similar to, because it's separate from all this other stuff as well. And so we find that in the brain, these models actually capture neural responses to language quite well. But of course, if we want to build models, they can capture responses to language understanding in a deep sense, right? Like reasoning on representations that we get from language. So it's not just kind of getting some coarse approximation of meaning,
很棒，因为它们就像是语言的纯净版。就像盒子里的语言。没有其他东西，感知、运动、概念都不在里面，对吧？只有语言统计数据，我认为人类语言系统可能与之类似，因为它也与所有这些其他东西分离开来。因此，我们发现大脑中这些模型实际上很好地捕捉到了对语言的神经反应。但当然，如果我们想建立模型，它们可以在深层意义上捕捉对语言理解的反应，对吧？比如对我们从语言中获得的表征进行推理。所以不仅仅是获得某种粗略的意义近似，
but actually doing some downstream reasoning on the things we get from linguistic input. Then I think we'll want to supplement these statistical language models with models of actual aspects of thought and reasoning, including social, social modeling of social like mental states. And there's exciting work happening in that direction at MIT and other places. So what else are you working on next? And what are the big questions that you still want to answer? Trying to use artificial neural network models as models of the mind and brain, I think it's a very promising direction. I think it's for the first time in the history of the kind of language research where we potentially can have
而是实际上对我们从语言输入中获得的东西进行后续推理。那么我认为我们将需要用实际的思维和推理模型来补充这些统计语言模型，包括对社会心理状态的社会建模。麻省理工学院和其他地方正在进行令人兴奋的研究。那么你接下来还在研究什么？你还想回答哪些重大问题？尝试使用人工神经网络模型作为思维和大脑的模型，我认为这是一个非常有前途的方向。我认为这是语言研究史上第一次，我们可能能够
some kind of a close to an algorithmic level understanding of how language processing might happen. And we can go beyond putting words like syntax on some blob on your brain and just leaving it at that, which is where the state of the art has been for many years. But now we can actually build some fully implemented models that do something that at least in some aspects look similar to humans. Of course, the goal here for us as science does not to build a model that's as close to the brain as possible. although that is one goal because then it can also afford certain things. But I'm more excited to understand what it is about these models that leads them to capture something about human behavior or human neural response.
在某种程度上接近算法层面，理解语言处理是如何发生的。我们可以超越将语法等词汇贴在大脑的某个区域上并就此打住，这是多年来该领域的技术水平。但现在我们实际上可以构建一些完全实现的模型，做一些至少在某些方面看起来与人类相似的事情。当然，我们科学的目标不是建立一个尽可能接近大脑的模型，尽管这也是一个目标，因为那样它也能提供某些东西。但我更兴奋的是了解这些模型中是什么导致它们捕捉到了人类行为或人类神经反应的某些方面。
And so we're doing a lot of experimentation now on these models, messing with them in various ways because we have full access to them, right? We can lesion them. We can train them in different ways. We can mess with their architectures and try to see what are the properties that the model needs to have to provide a good fit to human cognitive or neural mental spaces. And I'm also very excited to try to understand how language develops.
所以我们现在正在对这些模型进行大量实验，以各种方式摆弄它们，因为我们拥有对它们的完全访问权限，对吧？我们可以对它们进行损伤实验。我们可以用不同的方式训练它们。我们可以改变它们的架构，试图看看模型需要具备什么属性才能很好地拟合人类认知或神经心理空间。我也非常兴奋地尝试了解语言是如何发展的。
So I'm involved in some collaborations. It's a very hard, pain-thinking effort to try to collect neural responses from young kids because most of the action is happening between, say, I don't know, like nine months and kind of two years. Like that's the sweet spot of development where language kind of comes to be. It still develops a little bit after that. really the bulk of it is there by like two and a half, three, like it's, you know, almost all there. And there are people here and in a few other groups trying to develop tools to be able to test younger kids in the scanner with silent sequences, really fun paradigms, all sorts of kind of ingenuity, experimental ingenuity.
所以我参与了一些合作。尝试从幼儿那里收集神经反应是一项非常艰巨、费尽心机的努力，因为大部分活动发生在，比如说，九个月到两岁之间。那是语言开始形成的黄金时期。在那之后它还会继续发展一点，但真正的大部分在两岁半、三岁时就完成了，几乎全部都在那里。这里和少数其他小组的人正在尝试开发工具，以便能够在扫描仪中用静默序列测试更小的孩子，非常有趣的范式，各种各样的独创性，实验独创性。
And I think that could be another window to try to understand how language may relate to general reasoning abilities. as well as to kind of social perception, cognition, by looking at whether perhaps language shows, early language areas show more overlap with, for example, brain regions that support general kind of thinking and reasoning or areas that support some aspects of processing conspecifics, right, processing facial expressions, body language, thinking about others' intents and things like that. So hopefully in the next few decades we can make some headway. or maybe sooner. Well, those are big questions, and this is really great, great work that you're doing very interesting. Thank you so much for joining me today, Dr. Federenko.
我认为这可能是尝试理解语言如何与一般推理能力以及社会感知、认知相关联的另一个窗口，通过观察语言区域是否可能显示出与支持一般思维和推理的脑区，或者支持处理同类（即处理面部表情、肢体语言、思考他人意图等）某些方面的区域有更多的重叠。所以希望在未来几十年里我们能取得一些进展，或者也许更快。嗯，这些都是大问题，你所做的工作非常棒，非常有趣。非常感谢你今天加入我，费德连科博士。
That was really fun. Thank you so much. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combecingofpsycher or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you got your podcast today. And if you like what you're here, leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at Speaking of Psychology at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyen. Thank you for listening.
这真的很有趣。非常感谢。你可以在我们的网站 www.combecingofpsycher 上，或者在 Apple、Stitcher 或你今天获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》的往期节目。如果你喜欢你听到的内容，请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有意见或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 Speaking of Psychology at APA.org。《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪恩。感谢您的收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是美国心理学会的基姆·米尔斯。本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。